and here we are back at the Academy  Awards ladies and gentlemen now to  present the Award for Best Supporting  Actor last year's winner of the Best  Supporting Actress Award Miss Eva Marie  Saint the nominees for the Best  Supporting Actor are author Kennedy in  trial Jack Lemmon and mr. Roberts Joe  Montel and Marty Sal Mineo and rebel  without applause author O'Connell and  picnic the winner is Jack Lemmon  well since I have been in this end of  the entertainment industry had been very  fortunate in working with only the  highest of professionals I would like to  thank them for the help and the  opportunities they gave me and I thank  you all very much